vous avez fait quoi vous étiez malade
bouille était mal j'avais une laryngite
et grâce à jimmy mohamed image soignée
c'est moi m'a glacé qui vous a soigné
les flâneurs de danse de cortisone c'est
à beaucoup mieux beaucoup mieux vous
êtes sorti hier soir n'aura non pas du
tout chaud rester allongée tout à bâle a
juré vous avez la preuve vous êtes
certains billets de ce que vous voulez
je mets ma paye bien c'est vrai mais
terreau de paille du mont-houy
ah oui vous n'êtes pas sorti du tout la
journée hier pas du tout de la journée
pas du tout la journée vous êtes sûr je
vais peut-être sorti mon chien deux
minutes mais c'est tout voilà maintenant
moi je mets tout ce que vous voulez sur
la table non non sans vous sur vos
effectifs dit la vérité vous verrez
c'est ma véritable vous verrez l'été si
ce n'est pas la vérité
ah c'est la vérité si ce n'est pas la
vérité on est d'accord je ne vous paye
pas ce mois ci à babx saumon c'est
certain je les ai serré vérité les payer
double chooz non ah bon j'ai tout à
perdre en fait ouais bah oui j'ai menti
non pas mentir et en plus je ne mens pas
on verra bonsoir maxime gainey leurs
hôtes soient
je vais manquer ça c'est bon ouais
changement look energy de folie vraiment
rien
on a donné un long et venez pas à vous
et vous aimeriez m'a beaucoup manqué ah
ouais c'est vrai talent c'est vrai
vraiment je suis allé dans l'attenté les
couloirs comme ça comment elle va
canivet domini ça vient ça va bien un
père belge décide à elle tenu que dans
répondent et au nom de bell la presque
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais sans rigoler
comme ça au rouge voilà le rouge elle va
super mais là les haies les classes
rires non mais là en ce moment elle
prépare l'été j'ai l'impression que
c'est un modèle c'est isabelle
morini-bosc elle avait raison non mais
c'est vrai franchement vous êtes
magnifique en maillot vous ont ils
appellent moyenne parce qu'on maillot à
we were basé sur un flux le corry à la
bombe atomique du bourg madame chabot
vous faites de l'humour madame chabot
qu'aux non elle est magnifique en
maillot elle avait scié exceptionnelle
des gens elle a des jambes ils ont
souffert du froid annonce à vous tromper
alors c'est pas moi ce que j'aime c'est
géraldine savary plusieurs c'était